hello everyone this is Grandmaster Denis
Borgia and this is my greatest losses
[Music]
session so today I'm going to talk about
a few of my games that are not
necessarily painful but actually ones
that I learned a lot from but before I
start I want to show this position right
here which was played in Gaziantep but
my first question is if my opponent was
from the Philippines
can you guess who my opponent was yes
vastly so that's correct now the only
thing we need to guess is which color he
was and he was white yes indeed so when
you see this position you'll see that it
looks very plain and dull and I think
you're not even wrong I shouldn't be
worse with black do you'll see how that
will end and quite painfully for me all
right so before that I want to show a
different game that I played and that
was against like Wong Liam the same
tournament but before I start this one
and get into this tangent over and over
again I want to say that the under-20
World Championship is a very important
event when you play there you'll meet
all the future champions who will play
for super tournaments grand slams and
Olympic teams when I was playing in
Gaziantep I played like Wong Liam who's
a twenty seven hundred and one of the
best Vietnamese players also I played
best Li so who we all know who he is
again it's very interesting to point out
that
the winners of these events were usually
a good sign that they are going to
become a pro in chess or one of our top
10 players all right so let's start with
my game with laQuan Liam first this is
actually much much later after the
Weslie game I want two games in a row
then I lost and after that I was playing
back Wong Liam so I really wanted to
catch up because if I win this round in
the last round I would be white and
we'll have chances for some good places
all right so he plays this tricky rate e
d4 c6 d take c4 is anyone familiar with
this idea yes yeah it is the Slav III
but Kenny one guess my next move it's
kind of a funky tricky move that I play
it at that time it's not too good but
it's not even that great yeah f6 no not
that bad
I didn't want to resign on move 3 now I
really didn't want to play a 6a there so
just play Bishop e6 now obviously I was
hoping for an IG 5 which will not happen
why wouldn't I g5 be a horrible horrible
blunder yeah yep and sadly you can't
defend that night I could take obviously
I wasn't expecting that to happen
because we should be 6 is still a viable
line it's not a bad move it's a tricky
one just it has this extra take trick in
yeah so for example Knight c3 is the
main line here I can go Knight f6 and
for example you can even play like here
Knight g5 you're chasing away my bishop
go Bishop g4 f3 and now I have a choice
I can go here it's just quite normal
takes an e6 and this Knight is just as
funny as this Bishop on h5 but it's
quite playable for both now the other
idea is Bishop c8 which is kind of
tricky because if you take D 6 what
black is claiming here that you're
making like weird moves III f3 and the
knight on d5 and I just played the
normal Queens gambit and I'm gonna play
C 5 in the future and this is also
interesting probably slightly better for
white but it's not so bad the other line
and this is the main main line of this
variation is a for now as you mentioned
g6 is the idea
Nagi Bishop d5e for seemingly they're
trapping my bishop but I have one tricky
idea that saves the day how can I save
myself and the bishops like somewhat so
if you cannot move can't you can't do
anything always think about counter
attacking eight six yes and takes cuz if
the knight moves we take the pawn
otherwise he has to take the bishop but
then we can counter take his Knight
takes Knight takes c6 takes Bishop g7
and this is roughly equal even though
White has the bishop pair black is going
to castle soon and his position will be
alright now this line is very rare even
when this was played in 2008
so he played Queen c2 which is quite
solid now I could play b5 here which I
didn't do but the reason I didn't want
to do this I felt that a4 and after
taking and maybe even a potential b3
like for example if I do something
terrible like say here this Queenie for
ideas can become real issues and I'm
totally lost here so even though
obviously I wouldn't play g6 Bishop g7
but you get the idea that I have to be
really careful not to lose quickly if I
play b5 so I said no I'm not doing that
I'm just developing my knight takes
takes takes and we have to evaluate this
position a little bit what it wider
might achieve in this position
better development more space these
pawns yes to sender pawns I barely have
one and more pieces out now good for me
that the position is relatively closed
and I played the normal well actually
not the normal quite brave b5 move not
sure this is great actually
in fact I should have tried this idea
Queen c7 castles and now I have a really
nice little move here which is one of
the themes of the Slav variation and
anybody guess what move I should have
played here b5 how does that Oh II 5
sorry correct
b5 and this is actually how I should
have played because if d5 which is a bad
move we have this Knight b6 strict
double attacking the pawn and the Queen
and this is good for black and even if
they take Knight takes e5 you need not
be scared of this pin because I have
Bishop d6 and my next move is going to
chase away the Queen and castles and
this is really good for black now
obviously when I played this Bishop e6
sideline I wasn't really familiar with
the plans that's why you should be
really familiar with the structures you
play because if you know I would have
been able to find this plan of Queen c7
castles e5 and I would have a really
good game instead I played b5 now this
is kind of a daring move and trying to
grab more space but the downfall is that
this pawn will get weak and the b5 pawn
will get weak as well so that's not good
she played Queen e2 well if I take how
can i punish it I had a trick up my
sleeve if he would have taken on c6
rook c8 then I'll take your bishop these
are rare traps but the here it actually
works this would have been a nice way to
win but obviously a soon-to-be 2700
player will not fall for for this one so
played Queen e2e 6 Knight f6 now I saw
nothing better and if you see nothing
better at least Castle as quickly as
possible
efore there should be seven a6 so just
defended my pawns so if you look at this
position who would be rather rather be
[Music]
you're saying that you'd be fine with
being black if you manage to play c5 but
if not then you'd rather be white yeah
so yeah so this is kind of like a semi
Slav structure yes
although the bishops are missing which
is kind of good for me when my position
is still passive so you develop this
night castle rook c1 all standard stuff
h6 I like this move that I played
because I give a little bit of space for
my King then that can be useful rook c8
595 Knight takes d5 and now I'm at
choice I either take on h4
but then I will have some issues with my
pawns or I take that the e pawn on d5
notice that I can't take with the C pawn
cuz their take on c8 and I lose a piece
can't do that
so we're at choice now you'll have to
figure out a way to continue our play
what would you guys do
yeah this ship takes h4 and why not eat
xd5 why did you choose Bishop takes h4
good point so if you have a pawn on d5
then c5 is also becoming move yeah yeah
so the same way I also rejected eat eggs
d5 outright because I will have a
terrible structure and I would just be
worse for sure
so set okay helm a follow but I'll take
on h4 night be for a very nice smooth
he's immediately counter attacking now
if I play c5 I'll lose the a6 bond so I
didn't want to do that play it's
something that I wouldn't want to do but
I had no choice how can I defend my guys
it's not a pretty move but you have to
make it sometimes yes yes not proud of
it but you have to defend your pawns so
that kind of prompted him to jump on my
pawns played Queen e4 which is a nice
centralizing move and actually I'm quite
happy the way I started defending here
so it's a double attack you have to do
something about this because if you
don't we're going down badly so I played
Bishop g5 so either you start exchanging
stuff so let's say you take you didn't
do that take I can take even H stakes
but even if Queen takes that C say take
take take take take take I have some
counter play
I'm worse that's for sure but I'm still
fighting this Queen is active I'm in the
game probably that's the reason he
didn't take on g5 he said no no no no I
want you to stay passive played rook c3
and to be on this rook c3 does deserve
an exclamation mark because it holds the
position together it keeps pressure on
my position and you know I would not and
say yes you're still better but now I've
found a very nice tricky idea which
almost saves the day for me now if I
play Queen d7 they'll take on g5 and I
might get made it so I can't do that
exactly so I have to use the fact that
this Queen on e4 is a little bit
vulnerable
so my next move will be absurd Oh
sacrifice
I will temporarily sacrifice upon but
not that c5 and I don't go crazy with f5
either so we already know that this
Queen was a bit loose right on e4 I told
you the other thing there's only one
more piece that's kind of loosey-goosey
in White's position which piece is that
the b4 knife so I'm going to pester that
night a little bit
Queen a5 as I told you outplay AIDS we
and that's not doing too much
I played Queenie seven and this is a
tricky move and in fact laQuan Falls for
my trick here there's two moves that
white could play here taking the pawn or
not taking the pawn which one could be
the right solution yeah and you should
play mat d3 yes now probably he got
tempted and missed my idea but 93 would
be like a huge advantage for him that
slow squeeze and probably you know I'm
trying to hold this position but the
odds are not in my favor so but he took
on c6 but now I have a very nice
tactical idea that I spotted and
actually should have saved me this game
but we'll get there
look out there so Knight takes c6 and
now I came up with a nice defensive idea
yes rook takes c6 and actually yeah rook
takes c6 and I take yes Queen b7 and
actually this is a very very smart
little trick the big difference is if
you did this this order takes Queen b7
take you take you
rook c1 and sooner or later
taking on C it will be a real threat
even if rook d8 now this is a real
option of taking yeah yeah but rook
takes c6 and I think he missed this that
I can switch the ideas around and I
won't take on c6 until it's a pleasant
experience for me so Knight g5 takes
Luke c1 and black to move and make some
headway
yes so that my thought process here was
the following okay I have a slightly
worse position at least slightly worse
now I want to coordinate better
therefore I want my queen closer to my
pawns now I have a weak Bishop here and
a loose pawn on c6 therefore I play
Queen e7 to coordinate now if you lose a
weak pawn that sometimes activates your
position and that's one of the most
important things to learn that sometimes
giving away a weak pawn that was always
in the way and was kind of holding all
your pieces back they'll give you
southern activity I'm sure many of you
experienced that that when you lost one
of your pawns suddenly all your pieces
become much more alive and yeah that
kind of relates what you're asking me if
I need to know obviously you need to
know how to defend rook and games but
the most important part is not to be
afraid to lose upon if you get active
pieces so probably this Queen e7 was
inspired by that that I'm not really
scared of losing my weak pawn I might
get some play for it and it might just
be enough so Knight takes c6 and this
was a little little inaccurate I think
rook takes c6 takes Queen b7 and
probably this way of taking he missed
takes takes here and rook d8 and the
thing is he can't untangle so easily so
if he would just move the Queen to c2
now I can already take everything take
and this is not bad at all for me I'm
not even sure if I'm worse or even if
I'm worse I'm just slightly worse I
shouldn't lose this I might be even
better
so you meant age for and and I actually
made a mistake here if I would have
followed up with a precise idea here
probably I could have drawn the game in
fact I saw this idea but I was getting
too ambitious I actually cared a bit too
much about the result of the game hoping
to go for more and try to fight and
maybe win in the future but that's let's
be honest is not realistic here I should
have been focused on holding the
position yes Jesus g6 and what if they
take our pawns
yeah I mean it's good to trust that you
have a blockading position that's a good
thing to have the confidence that it
should be good enough and to be honest
I'm also confident that this should be
fine for a black but if you can take
stuff from your opponent try take all
the material that they give you it
should be a hint of how I should
continue here yes yes this
this would have been much better than
what I did because again he can't
untangle has to take on h4
now my next move is obvious my takes c6
rook takes c6 and now I have a nice move
very nice move
yes rook takes d4 and well when you play
these moves on the board you kind of get
this exhilarating feeling of oh I'm
invincible there's no check that would
punish me and if you calculate well and
you worked hard on your puzzles it'll
show that yes there's no way for Y to
win this and after this because of the
equal pawns vibe we'll have to sell for
a perpetual check but as I told you
before unfortunately I became too
ambitious and was hoping that oh let's
have a fighting game and somehow maybe
I'll win she's not necessarily a bad
thing but in this position I could have
just gone for this line and to be honest
with you I saw this Knights at Knight
takes c6 rook takes c6 rook d4 I saw
this whole line and shows this
unpractical decision of continuing the
fight when actually I spent like 15
minutes thinking on this and we were
kind of heading toward some trouble we
move 26 so that's kind of normal so took
on c6 which wasn't good rook takes c6 G
takes h4 and the Queen c2 and this is a
very nice move by laQuan BM I can't take
on d4 anymore because rook c8 and my
pieces are still passive
how would you evaluate this position if
I would give you this as a puzzle and
say okay you look at this position who's
better who's worse is the position equal
can anybody tell me how would you feel
about this position what would be your
objective evaluation what do you think I
had the feeling so I start first is that
I should be fine that was my feeling how
would you feel about this position if
you were black yeah yes
yeah I would agree after the game I
would agree with you that it is easier
for white to play especially because of
these active pieces now they are not
super duper much better than the Queen
and this rook but it's better so Queen
c2 g6 and rubbed e6 to be honest I don't
even know why I don't give this even
more credit but probably this rook d6
give gives the most chances for him and
to be honest with you I think this is
the difference between a 2700 player and
an average Grand Master or 2600 plus is
that they find the most challenging
moves in dull dull positions so in this
position I was quite sure I'm not going
to lose this game if I manage to bring
my Queen to d5 probably I was correct
therefore he chooses roob d6 so I cannot
achieve that at all
these challenging moves usually mean
it's not that they're super good but at
least they stop you from finding the
most effective plans so you have to find
new ones and another one and another one
but okay rook c8 Queen the three rook
sees Queen c7 King h2 not one thing to
get into Queen c1 checks and queen f-4s
and queen sita's
and again I have a tough choice to make
here how to continue my play one of the
moves here is stronger than the other
obviously we should invade White's
position because we need to find some
counter play what should we play here
yeah you see - okay anybody else guesses
would anyone want to play Queen c1 in
fact I'll switch it around what's the
difference between Queen c2 and green c1
yes mm-hmm and what would Queen c1 try
to achieve in fact yeah good mm-hmm yeah
queen semen is perpetual check themes
Ryan yeah same thing yeah so Queens c1
has these perpetual ideas so that that
convince anyone that they will play
Queen C 1 instead of Queen C - no so I
guess we've all been fooled by wanting
to exchange Queens I also played Queen
c2 and it turns out to be not so good
Queen c1 would be better because of
these perpetual ideas and taking on B -
now might would stop that doesn't want
to see a queen on f4 we take upon clean
f6
and what's amazing that black will need
to play something like rook f8 and the
computer says confidently that it's a
draw you're drawing now it's not
something you do confidently when you
have like 10 minutes left all of those
white pieces are attacking your king and
the commuter huh draw there's another
problem yeah Magnus cross is a good
player but nobody's better than
objective moves so if the position is
objectively equal you're supposed to
hold the position regardless who do you
play with all due respect to Carlson I
believe that good moves should surface
to defend the position and that's what I
think I mean not many could prove it but
I think that's the truth
so Queen c1 should objectively be the
best chance and should be holding but
it's scary and that's when the computer
said and maybe it's not even the
objective truth in fact in this case I
might even agree with you that maybe
Magnus could find the right moves for
white in that specific position coming
back to this one and just find the right
moves for white and the attack would
just crash through I could believe that
but if there's enough defensive
resources left probably I could be able
to hold this but I definitely I should
have played this one
so I played Queen c2 but then he came up
with this very nice idea of Queen III
obviously avoiding the exchange 5
I played a 5 which is not great I again
should have taken the pawn and it's kind
of funny because fortunately was famous
for taking all these pawns and then
surviving and it turns out that
sometimes you should eat lots of lots of
pawns to stay healthy the move here is
d5 and I challenge you to find the only
move in this position there's only one
move that saves the game and it's one of
the weirdest-looking once that's what I
wanted to show you guys it's black to
move and equalize
so the big threat of white is to take on
e6 and just break break up the black
kingside yes eat eggs e5 I will push on
through with upon Oh No I will push
through and I will just destroy your
bone structure f6 is never really a good
idea yeah any ideas Queen takes 8 so I
can still take on e6 and and again I'll
just be too quick with my attack so we
have enough pieces with black so
exchanges would favor us that's why he
takes d5 seems so logical that's true
there's one brilliant move that saves
the day no this is already computer
analysis I unfortunately didn't find it
but it's actually logical rook e8 this
looks extremely extremely passive but if
you think about it it makes some sense
because if you take rook takes if you
exchange it off you don't have enough
material left to make me and if you
don't exchange it then where will you
give me mate so that's kind of check
King g7 if you take take then you can't
make me that one Queen so I'm not saying
wookie e8 is impossible to find I'm just
saying it's not too easy to find in
general especially with a ticking clock
yeah yeah I mean if your petrosyan
probably you find rook e8 in like a
split second like if you're more
defensive inclined probably okay rook e8
is an easy move for you but otherwise if
you don't relish defending these kind of
positions rook e8 is not that easy when
anyways that would have been the best
defense and the last chance for me to
defend this game
a5 can now d5 Queen f5 obviously I
didn't want to take because e 6 the
problem is twofold
if I take then this should be super
duper checkmate and if I don't take then
that's the problem and he can just start
rolling with all those pieces even Queen
e5 just Queenie five good yeah the Queen
e5 is good
f 6 of preen takes d5 ah d 8 that's it
here take techie 7 it's a pin so I have
to play creamy fun so this is very
uncomfortable for black therefore I
didn't want to take on d5 played Queen
f5 take stakes f3 look at fate rook d7
and now maybe maybe all is not lost
I think this is the last chance I have
one move to make and maybe hope to
survive every other move losers in the
move I made was losing obviously but
what should we play here and hope for
survival yes no in fact you're right I
should have tried clean f4 maybe it
loses but at least it's a real gang game
and maybe you can hope for something
brah obviously white is better or maybe
even winning but I should have tried to
get into the sand game and this was my
last chance and even if you start
counting I've got plenty of chances to
survive in the beginning I had a create
clear equal variation then I had the
screen takes B to first Queen c1 and
Queen takes v2 and then Queen takes B to
rook e8 rook e8
so you get your chances I played g5 but
then he found a very nice move and after
that I'm just completely lost
and if you know what black is planning
to do it's quite easy yes black does
want to play Queen f4 so how can we stop
the Queen from moving to f4 deform and
basically this ends the game because I
cannot exchange the Queen's anymore and
my pawns are just too weak and actually
what gave counter chances to me in this
whole game was my active rook and clean
without those I would be dead lost and
now I am that lost unfortunately rook g4
just attacking my weak pawn also putting
the rook on a safe spot King g6
I have to defend what you can Queen c5
rook b8 just defending green f8 hoping
to exchange but obviously but not
exchange Queens keep giving great offers
and to no avail
f4 and it's basically over here and the
game was done so I've got few chances to
save the game I have a slightly worse
from the opening but you always get
second chances if you try hard enough
and I think what I learned from this
game is that if you calculate and you
set enough problems you might eventually
draw or if we're thinking of how he
played this game he was posing problems
enough problems that his opponent would
trip up and that's how he won all right
so let's take a look at game 2 and that
game is my game against vastly so so now
this was played in round 3 I won the
first game in the under-20 World
Championship drew against on out 26:20
player Lennox Luka
but white and then in the third round I
was playing lastly so who we all know
now vastly so was unknown at that moment
when you're playing in 2008 so I didn't
know exactly what to expect
although I already heard some news that
there's a very talented kid from the
Philippines when our plays for America
so I played this very line which which
is called the Philidor system and I was
kind of quite kind of confident when I
played this line because I played this
against who he found and actually in our
game Budapest I was even better and had
chances to win even though it ended in a
draw wasn't actually a very entertaining
game now Leslie decided to take on e5
take take Bishop g5 recently I saw some
players play Bishop c4 or even f4 he
pried away let's play Bishop g5 now
Knight d5 is kind of annoying so we need
to stop that and I played c6 Bishop c4
King e8 now Bishop e6 is another idea
taketake and this structure looks ugly
but it's kind of easy to defend those
pieces and even when you would get
around with your Bishop you're not doing
too much damage because these pieces
just defend the fact forever
it might even go Knight h5 take or just
put the knight on f4 yes yeah so these a
sixty five pawns do give me some
outposts for my Knights and take away
yours on d5 and f5 so it's not
necessarily that bad
but it's not that I wanted to do that so
I played King gate Knight f3 and this
was rare and kind of surprised me
because you usually see played at f4 and
trying to open up the position
he played at night f3 which seemed
strange to me I felt that I should have
no problems in this position 97 Castle
Bishop e7 and here he played a very very
nice prophylactic move and these moves
are the hardest yes yes so he wants to
keep the bishop and also he feels that
my e5 pawn is a little bit loose so he
can try and attack that Bishop h4 but
then I came up with this plan of nygean
m6 because I felt that if I stabilize
the e5 pawn what will be your long-term
plans white and I wasn't totally wrong
but again he played an ID to again I
really like so you'll see why
and I think here I made a mistake
probably I'm still equal here because
all the white pieces are quite passive
and no f4 ideas really work because I
have full control of the e5 square if we
think about this position logically you
might be able to find the correct land
for a block actually what's blacks
biggest dilemma what's what would we
like to get rid of the bishop on see it
is terrible so let's get rid of that guy
how can we get rid of that guy
not affect you can be you're not a fit
or you can get a bit more active yes so
you can do not have fade but why not
night c5 yeah
they played b5 which is not that good
night c5 and the next move being Bishop
e6 and if I manage to play Bishop e6 I
definitely not worse here now I played
b5 but here vastly comes up with a
brilliant solution I mean I was then
deeply impressed after the game and I'm
still impressed with this game by rusty
his next move is very nice it's not much
of a tactical move it's more like a
positional decision yes yep
he goes Bishop e6 and this is a
fantastic positional decision I think
because he realized probably that
wherever he puts the bishop it does
nothing and it's just a useless piece so
he said okay my bishop is not needed for
my concept on the other hand if your
bishop will be missing after this move
b5 who will defend all your weaknesses
on the Queen side so Bishop e6 Knight c5
and the main point is that he will take
my bishop this time because I already
advanced with this pawns and as we know
pawns don't go backwards takes f3 and
probably this one's one of the second
opportunities I had to change the course
of the game what should I play here
what should I play here
yes I felt maybe bit too confident with
my position because my position looked
very safe and maybe it's still safe but
it was time to go reckless somewhat and
I mean if he has to go here then it's
just funny but if he goes here takes
here takes I still feel uncomfortable
with being black here because of these
palm weaknesses and he will jump around
that the nights I feel I'm slightly
worse i I think honestly I'm slightly
worse here but I still should have
initiated some complications because
you'll see what happens if I don't so
nine eight six Bishop f2 has bishop f2
such a strong move well bid it's a
strong move because it kind of just
shoots at my knight on c5 and also
points out that hey fellow you have a
weakness on a7 rook c7 so I had to
defend night b3 and look how every move
he makes comes with a Tempe again I have
to react now I went back to e6 which I
still prefer although maybe taking C
takes King f7 as a possibility but this
is just kind of easy play for him he can
go King B Vaughn rook c1 rook d1 double
double that all the pieces and I'm in
for a long struggle and I'm gonna
struggle this whole game so I felt no I
don't want to make it easy on you so I
just post a knight on e6 which is
actually useful because it does control
many important squares so it's not quite
clear if I'm which is going to go down
so soon
rook d2 and actually rugged e2 might
have been a little bit inaccurate I have
a good idea here but black that I didn't
do and probably I should have done so as
you can see I'm slightly worse again in
this game after this b5 move just the
small concession and I'm already a
little worse how can I kind of bother
why it's position yes
yeah Bishop b4 that's what I should have
done and let's say a three takes takes
he still has huge control of squares but
at least I exchanged something off maybe
I go King g7 you go here I go rook
something or knight of seven and and I
equal in this position definitely not
am I still fighting am I in the game yes
I am
but knight of seven he could have played
a three already he waited a bit longer
and still have the Bishop b4 idea
outplayed h5 but after a three I have no
more moves left and to be honest this
really impressed me that I have all my
pieces on the board yet none of them can
move and this is not the worst
where it is still to come g6 there
should be 3 H 4 HP so he's not rushing
staking away all the possible ideas I
might have said play f5 and my mind you
I'm not playing bad moves the computer
likes my moves it's just that I don't
have enough space takes takes and here
he comes up with a very remarkable
positional idea
which actually will decide the game I
think even here I felt kind of confident
that everything's fine
I don't see why I'm losing what after he
found this plan I wasn't so sure anymore
so what we'll need to find a square
where he could invade my position from
I already covered these important
squares d5c 5d 4d 4f 4 so you'll have to
look other in other places actually
breakthrough yes yes exactly that's what
he did not a - obviously I can't open up
the position that would be suicidal and
I can't stop this night b4 idea let's
say I wait the night before now if I
take I'm like dying on the black squares
if I don't take the night a 6 is coming
and I'm dying on c5
so with this long-range nice plan of a
three night a - my position totally
collapses so I played c5 but that's the
beginning of the end because he has a
very nice move here it's simple but very
nice
now I blogged this before squared that's
not a problem anymore
now it jumps back and now that's a big
problem because the night is heading to
d5 and then big problems are coming so
94 I'm trying to blockade f4 is just
destroying my fortress takes e4 and this
is the best way you can fight you're
trying to keep the position closed
because if it's closed maybe maybe
you'll get some fighting chance but
objectively this is already not good
news for me 95 rooks e-66 rook d7 now
9th ik c 7 is a great decision by him
saying okay I give away this beautiful
knight on d5 but in exchange I get all
of my pieces in to attack you yep and he
wins upon to rook g8 I'm still looking
for a counter play and whenever and
whoever you're playing always look for
counter play so I'm still trying I'm
still fighting and trying to hit on weak
spots in his position but obviously
that's not gonna work 96 Bishop f2 now
he's rounding up of my h4 pawn Knight c8
still being tricky rook g7 but a counter
trick so he wants to exchange on his
terms and even if I would take on a7 he
would take my rook and it would be still
bad
rook d8 takes and the rest is just agony
Czech takes King d4 trying to bank on
that lone active pawn but it's obviously
not doing much here and the rest is just
the end
still trying but obviously is just lost
and it's just lost so in fact what I
learned from this game is don't rush
with your pawns they never move
backwards and if you would manage to
exchange that Bishop on c8 without
actually having concessions you might
equalize but making few inaccuracies in
the end might just cost you a game
against the future 2,800 play thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Music]